[Music]
chadwick boseman's death after a
four-year battle with colon cancer
stunned and devastated fans around the
world
but perhaps no one is feeling it more
than his now widow
taylor simone ledward
chadwick was a massively celebrated
public figure but he was
always quiet about his personal life and
his relationship
the couple was first linked in 2015 but
chadwick
never commented on his status with the
california state polytechnic university
grad
who majored in music studies and served
as the lead singer of the school's jazz
band
now we're taking a closer look at their
sweet love story
the two were first spotted showing off a
little pda
in june 2017 when they were seen holding
hands in la
after his appearance on jimmy kimmel
live chadwick
boseman is a name that you would i
immediately think oh he must be a
billionaire
hey that's that's what we're shooting
for
we gotta fake it till you make it the
couple was still going strong
in february 2018 when chadwick brought
her to the nba
all-star game in la a month later
celebrity gossip website the young black
and fabulous reported that
simone's sister commented on an insta
pic of the a-lister with his black
panther love interest
lupita nyong'o when a fan wrote that she
wished the two were a couple in real
life
simone sis reportedly chimed in writing
his real-life queen is gorgeous
and together they embody true love not
to mention they would make some
beautiful babies
it's a beautiful thing the couple worked
the red carpet at the screen actors
guild awards in january 2019
grinning ear to ear and holding hands
simone was also by her man's side at the
2019 oscars
a month later chadwick publicly thanked
his leading lady at the 2019
naacp image awards when he won the award
for outstanding actor in a motion
picture for his performance in black
panther
simone you're with me every day i have
to acknowledge you right now love you
some fans also now think that his speech
may have subtly hinted at some of his
health struggles
you know they say black people always
thank god when they win and i'm not
going to let you down
they thank you god for uh
not not just winning um
thank you god for the trials and
tribulations that you allow us to go
through
so that we can we can appreciate these
moments we can appreciate the joy
that comes um from winning
in november 2019 the couple posed
together at the premiere of 21 bridges
and if you look closely you can see she
was sporting what appeared to be
an engagement ring the two appeared to
be in great spirits in february at the
nba
all-star game in chicago simone rocking
that
engagement bling and on friday
chadwick's family revealed he married
simone before his death
referring to her as his wife in their
statement
chadwick was diagnosed with stage 3
colon cancer in 2016
and battled with it these last four
years as it progressed to stage four
he died in his home with his wife and
family
by his side
[Music]
you